jo était les français seraient
favorables à ce que les gilet jaune
stoppent leur manifestation c'est un
sondage est là qui a été publiée à deux
jours 56% des français donc son pour que
ça s'arrête
et c'est aussi la question du jour sur
le figaro et ça conforte un petit peu ce
point de vue puisque vous êtes 71%
mais là sur la base du volontariat donc
ce n'est pas un sondage représentatif de
la population française a considéré que
les manifestations des gilets jaunes
doivent s'arrêter
et alors ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est que il y a des gilet jaune
eux-mêmes qui trouvent qu'il faut que ça
s'arrête
ou plus exactement on va écouter
benjamin cauchy et un gilet jaune de
haute garonne qui considère qu' il faut
sortir des villes parce que c'est la
seul moyen de se débarrasser des
casseurs figurez vous écoutez le c'est
le français qui commence en avoir marre
de voir les centres villes qui sont
notamment un fils a investi par les
casseurs et c'est ces casseurs là qui
viennent poser problème au sein des
manifestations
donc la france des ronds-points qui est
à l'origine qui est à l'origine du
mouvement
ou bien doit reprendre doit reprendre la
force moi j'invite tous les gilet jaune
est bien dans leurs villages dans leur
commune la france des territoires
oubliés et bien sortir des hyper centre
des centres-villes et à repartir et il
va repartir dans l'est dans les
périphéries tout simplement
alors comment sa part le constat
frédéric david du haut de votre tour de
contrôle de sondeurs est ce que vous
voyez l'opinion qu'ils changent d'avis
oui clairement
elle bouge pour la première fois dans
une enquête ifop pour atlantico le
soutien pure est passé sous les 30%
il était de 29% au tout début de du
mouvement des gilets jaunes ils étaient
2 51% alors bien sûr le soutien puis sa
sympathie reste majoritaire à hauteur de
55%
mais c'est nettement moins que pour des
catégories sociales par exemple les
infirmières ou d'autres segments pour
lesquelles le soutien étaient les plus
forts dans que lorsqu'il y avait des
mouvements sociaux
quand même les français font toujours
une sorte de dissociation entre la
violence et les gilets jaunes quand bien
même des gilets jaunes ont commis des
actes de violences par contre ce qui a
bougé ces identifications la proximité
identificatoires au mouvement sur le
mode du je suis gêné jaune je me sens
chez les gens on est passé de plus de
20% pas ce qui est beaucoup dans une
logique d'extrapolation et qui peut
donner une idée de potentiel électoral
pour les élections européennes à moins
de 10%
et puis oui il y a
une vraie usure une vraie lassitude de
l'opinion qui entre parenthèses c'est
votre deuxième thème a grandement permis
la remontée ada partielle de la cote de
popularité du président de la république
en termes de rempart contre la chienlit
comme mon design et pacino alors on
pouvait vous vous sentez gilet jaune
moi je il ya certaines n'ont pas
revendications parce que j'ai toujours
considéré que ce n'était pas tellement
une offre politique mais c'était une
demande et donc dans les deux manches
j'appellerais ça plutôt des demandes que
de véritables revendications il ya des
choses qui me paraissent depuis le début
essentiel et notamment sur le sentiment
d'être pris entre 1o désignés comme les
élites qui font sécession d'une certaine
manière parce qu'elles n'ont pas besoin
des services publics elle utilise - les
services publics que que d'autres donc
le l'absence de services publics leur
manque - et là où elles vivent dans les
villes les grandes villes il ya un accès
facile et puis vers le bas dès le début
moi j'ai remarqué ça dès les premières
même mobilisation et dans les premières
discussions avec des gilets jaunes
c'était nous voulons vivre de notre
travail décemment de notre travail nous
ne voulons pas dead mais justement si je
vous ai posé cette question c'est parce
que cette revendication
elle reste légitime donc pour moi que ça
s'arrêterait c'est tout à fait essentiel
à mon avis il ya deux choses d'abord un
mouvement social au sens général du
terme
aussi l'on sait c'est extrêmement
difficile à maintenir à un niveau de
mobilisation important parce que on en a
pas vu dans notre histoire contemporaine
et puis la deuxième chose c'est qu'il y
a eu quand même des éléments de réponse
on a eu les annonces du président de la
république en décembre les fameux 10
milliards tout ce qu'on peut dire sur
ces 10 milliards le grand débat ça vient
d'être dit des aussi des stratégies de
division d gilet jaune de stratégie
politique tout à fait logique quand on a
quand on est face à un tel mouvement
d'essayer de trouver des angles de
trouver des moyens d'enfoncer descoings
dans ce mouvement et ça a quand même
plutôt réussi c'est à dire que on l'a vu
et ça va continuer j'imagine avec les
velléités de constituer des listes pour
les européennes il y a effectivement
dans les gilets jaunes aujourd'hui une
multiplicité de d'aspiration de
positionnement politique de l'extrême
gauche d'ailleurs à droite on voit bien
que même à intermas de la liste ils sont
pas d'accord voilà ce qu'il en soit cela
se mobiliser et là on est plus dans la
mobilisation philippe meyer est ce qu'il
est temps que ça s'arrête ce mouvement
c'est à dire on voit pas très bien ce
que c'est devenu au départ il ya cette
revendication d'être gouvernés de plus
près d'avoir son mot à dire de ne pas
être soumis à des décrets ou des occases
technocratique qui nivelle absolument
tout que ce soit à propos du 80
kilomètres à l'heure que ce soit à
propos des décisions qui sont prises
et puis au fur et à mesure des semaines
ça disparaît dans le paysage au profit
de leader dont certains disent des
choses complètement l'effrayante comme
ce type qui s'est fait piéger par notre
confrère parle aux navy de deux lances à
challans en chalencon et qui explique
qu'il a des paramilitaires qui sont tout
près il avait déjà demandé que le
général de vie écrit d'ailleurs je crois
qu agréable avec général de ses parents
plus de 15 heures mais il y en a
quelques autres qui sont aussi effrayant
que celui là et puis après il ya des
gilets jaunes qui veulent faire des
listes mais à peine ont ils commencé à
faire des listes qu'ils se reproduisent
par scissiparité qu ils s'engueulent qui
s'apostrophent qu'on les voie plus donc
quand vous êtes devant ça et que vous
avez sympathisé que vous avez même
ressenti vous même la justesse de ce qui
était dit à la mi-novembre
vous vous dites mais où s'est passé tout
ça ça a déclenché quelque chose qui est
intéressant dont on parlera sans doute
tout à l'heure qui est ce ce début de
grands débats qui d'ailleurs a l'air
d'intéresser les français si j'ai bien
compris mais frédéric le sait mieux que
moi mais il ya un début d'intérêt pour
ce grand débat est de moins en moins de
compréhension pour les gilet jaune avec
le fait qu'on peut toujours expliqué que
c'est pas qui etc
mais c'est à l'occasion de leur
mouvement que la casse et pas n'importe
laquelle se répand ses parts en dessous
des trucs antisémites qui sont infecte
et au milieu de tout ça je pense que
c'est même pas l'idée c'est pas il faut
que ça s'arrête c'est que c'est en train
de s'épuiser dans la confusion s'arrête
demain je vous donne quelques points de
vue d'internautes qui nous suivent
évidemment en direct à la fois sur
lefigaro.fr et sur twitter hashtag point
de vue citoyen payant nous dit stop et
les manif du samedi pourquoi pas changer
de mode d'action certainement et
il y aura nous dit pourquoi dans une
démocratie est il impossible de se
déplacer librement et ce chaque samedi
déplorons que les mesures de sécurité
qui sont nécessaires par ces
manifestations
babylon oudiste intéressant cette
question me gêne faut-il que ça s'arrête
car il me semble que la décision revient
aux manifestants ce n'est pas à nous de
décider
c'est vrai même si on peut avoir un
point de vue c'est d'ailleurs l'objet
même de cette émission et je suis sûr
que vous ne comprenez cher babines et
aux citoyens payeurs encore lui le dit
les gilet jaune vont muter en rancoeur
jaune le mouvement est hétéroclite de
toute façon finalement tu as dit cortès
campagne qu'avait ce jd je n'avais pas
encore vu
c'est un nouveau porte parole parce que
porte parole mais on a l'impression que
c'est comme les jeux d'argent mac os si
le gilet jaune de haute-garonne lido
partir hors délai à la campagne ça va
être calme
oui ben il faut aller raconter ça aux
gens qui étaient du côté de notre dame
des landes ne crois pas que la campagne
apporte un calme tandis qu'il est juste
un point juste là dessus ce que dit
effectivement ce porte-parole dévier les
jaunes est intéressant mais ils n'ont
été entendu qu'à partir du moment où ils
sont venus dans les villes et
malheureusement qu'à partir du moment où
il ya eu de la casse à paris et ça c'est
un point très important parce que
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient la casse à paris
est en fait le 1er décembre
samedi 1er décembre on se rappelle de
ces images absolument terrible autour de
la place de l'étoile et c est bien là de
triomphe il jusqu'à ce moment là ils
n'ont pas été c'est même pas entendu ils
n'ont pas été écoutés et là
effectivement s'ils repartent sur les
rond points et ne gêne que
les gens qui sont comme eux d'une
certaine manière pourrait-on dire
salaberry crcc sociologie rapide et bien
ils ne gêneront plus personne anthony
cortese finalement qu'est-ce qui a eu
raison des gilet jaune c'est les
casseurs c'est l'extrême gauche c'est
leurs divisions internes
justement ce qui est ce qui est drôle à
observer c'est que ce qui va les tuer
finalement c'est ce qui faisait leur
force beauté est finie quand vous disent
qu'il va les tuer pas encore mais ça ne
saurait tarder malheureusement non
malheureusement pour eux en tout cas ce
qui va les tuer c'est ce qui faisait sa
force
à l'origine c'est à dire cette
spontanéité et cette organisation
quelque part horizontale
ils ont renoncé complètement à désigner
des chefs a désigné une cause et
aujourd'hui on voit un mouvement qui n'a
ni queue ni tête qui ne n'a plus de
raison malheureusement n'existe qu'il ne
trouve pas et justement on parle voilà
de est-ce que le mouvement devrait
prendre les villes les ronds-points à
nouveau moi je pense plutôt qu'il doit
revenir à ses joueurs et à ses origines
c'est à dire reprendre possession
d'internet et c'est à dire prendre
possession du terrain du gouvernement
saisir le débat le gouvernement a mis en
place le grand débat certains jugent les
jeunes ont mis en place le vrai débat
c'est à dire c'est une sorte de contre
plate forme face à face à ce débat là et
je pense justement que le gilet jaune
prouveront un avenir justement dans le
fait d'être davantage constructif plutôt
que de faire défiler chaque samedi qui
qui quelque part au fini de la célèbre
débouche pas sur grand chose
frédéric dabi je voudrais vous soumettre
cette réaction intéressante de nos
internautes anti mac il nous dit si les
gilet jaune perdre la partie
l'humiliation risque de conduire à des
violences plus grave en fait oui est ce
que finalement il ne serait pas mieux
que ça continue un petit peu a existé ne
serait ce que pour servir d'exutoire
est ce qu'ils ont perdu la partie ça se
défend les annonces dont parlait laurent
bouvet du 10 décembre ont quand même
marqué les esprits ils ont contré un
milliard d'euros mickael ont contribué à
éteindre une partie de l' incendie
notamment chez les reçus et des
retraités un passé de 1200 euros comme
j'irai
tranchoir pour payer la csg à 2000 euros
ça change la donne et ça explique aussi
la remontée très forte du président la
république chez les catégories retraité
et âgé alors c'est vrai que perdre la
partie
ils ont face à eux un double double
débouchés celui du celui du grand débat
est-ce qu'ils ont investis vraiment
c'est discutable et ils ont un vrai
débouché quête de débouché électoral
d'une campagne qui commence à peine mais
comme ça a été dit très très bien la
limite c'est que l'histoire de ce
mouvement au delà de la forte résonance
de leur mot d'ordre avec des craintes
niché au coeur du peuple français la
crainte du de la crainte du déclassement
la focalisation sur le pouvoir d'achat
le sentiment d'être dépendant de sa
voiture il ya encore deux tiers des
français qui répondent par l'affirmative
y compris dans les grandes villes ça
bien raisonné c'est ce qui explique
aussi ce soutien qui a ce malgré tout ce
sous de cette source est ce soutien et
sa sympathique qui reste malgré tout
fort tu sais aussi que comment produire
une offre électorale cohérente quand
l'histoire de ce mouvement c'est une
délégitimation systématique de tout
porte parole par leur propre père tout
faux présentation de toute augmentation
donc voilà où ira-t-il ministre je n'en
sais rien et ne réside plus tôt 2 3 ou 4
0 c'est probable et ce ne sera pas le
même effet soit il y en a une
et s'il y en a quatre évidemment ça
change mais il y aura un effet de 10
passion vous parliez à l'instant du
grand débat frédéric dabi c'est vrai que
ça fait un mois que le pression la
république a lancé cette initiative qui
est pour lui l'occasion